plus qu'une simple maison en plein coeur
de donzy derrière cette façade le moulin
de maupertuis et sa roue à aubes
entraînée par le no1 depuis des siècles
est enfin allé d'un plan qui va laisser
passer à lille et dans le de meunier ici
mais un musée créé en 1989 est consacré
à cette activité
27 ans et un nécessaire coup de jeune
depuis quelques mois
en 27 ans d'existence on a amoncelés des
choses il ya des choses qui ont pris la
poussière et on avait donc besoin de toi
l'été pour redonner de l'intérêt au
public une transformation en profondeur
pour remettre le lieu au niveau des
attentes des visiteurs maquette
valorisation des objets et des
collections mais aussi nouveaux panneaux
tout un travail pour raccorder le
bâtiment à son contexte
ce qu'il faut c'est de la scénographie
donc il faut aussi à billère un aspect
visuel qui attire l'oeil du visiteur
donc avec la présence de machines
d'objets et après ensuite de fans aux
dons scientifique qui apporte un
complément d'information visiteurs ça va
venir
royer le blé ils sont près de 2200 à
venir chaque année découvrir l'édifice
au coeur de la visite la transformation
du blé en farine et le parcours des
grains entre les nombreuses machines
la plupart datent de la fin du 19e
siècle et elle reste le principal atout
du moulin pour les visiteurs on a pu
voir que bah tout les mâles et machine
en marche et voir enfin si le traitement
de du blé et de la farine
donc c'était très intéressant s'il
pouvait y avoir quoi on se libère
remettre le moulin en fonctionnement
complet avec voir un cycle complet de
deux réalisations de la farine donc en
partant du gain et en allant jusqu à la
farine fini ce serait plutôt plaisant la
modernisation du lieu se poursuivra dans
les prochains mois en parallèle d'un
autre chantier
l'installation d'une turbine pour que le
moulin produire sa propre électricité